wir sprechen jetzt über die Grüne Partei
heute die Regierungspartei ist die heute
seit fast einem Jahr eben mitregiert in
ganz Deutschland im Bund nämlich und
über die jetzt bei Wagenknecht gesagt
hat die Partei ist gefährlich und das
macht sie an Inhalten fest an der
Energiepolitik vor allen Dingen ist das
alles Quatsch was die Linke sagt also
zuerst als ich das gehört habe ich
gesagt okay Moment also die
gefährlichste Partei ist die AFD die dem
Bundestag sitzt und dann hat Herr
Bartsch sie zurechtgewiesen und hat das
ebenso gesehen und dann habe ich mir
gedacht wenn Bartsch der Wagenknecht in
die Parade fährt dann muss er doch was
dran sein oder habe ich noch mal
nachgedacht und bin zu dem Schluss
gekommen die AFD ist nicht gefährlich in
dem Sinne weil sie nicht in der
Regierung sitzt sie sitzt in keiner
Landesregierung es ist in keine
Bundesregierung und das wird hoffentlich
lange so bleiben also ist die Partei vor
der ich mir Sorgen mache
ich würde gefährlich nicht sagen aber es
ist die Partei
die mir am
schlimmsten den Tag versorgen
weil sie eine Partei ich sag mal so eine
Lehre zu einer Partei ist die nur
reguliert dir nur Befehl die Ratschläge
erteilt die ich mag es jetzt mal am
Beispiel fest wenn herr Kretschmann mir
erzählen will dass ich mich am besten
mit dem Waschlappen waschen soll und
dass ich nur ein Zimmer heizen soll
jetzt machen wir die aktuelle
Energiekrise und
in der Innenstadt nur noch mit
lastenfahrrädern gefahren werden soll
also alles das was uns zurückführt eine
die Industrialisierung die durch die
Energiepolitik zwangsläufig kommt und da
sage ich das war nicht der Sinn meines
Lebens dass ich mit 74 im nächsten
Jahrzehnt wieder dorthin komme wo ich
herkomme einmal selbstkritisch dazu viel
erhobene Zeigefinger zu viel
Vorschriften zu viel Verbote in ihrer
Partei durch ihre Partei
also ich bin immer wieder total erstaunt
das hat sich ja offenbar vor 20 30
Jahren irgendetwas festgesetzt dass
jetzt immer wieder reflexartig
hervorgeholt wird wenn es darum geht das
grüne die ihr in 11 Ländern und
wahrscheinlicher bald in dem 12
Bundesland mit Regierungsverantwortung
tragen seit gut einem Jahr und ich bin
sehr froh darüber dass die Grünen als
Stimme der Vernunft in dieser
Bundesregierung am Ruder mit sitzen in
einer noch nie da gewesenen
Krisensituation Verantwortung tragen
russland hat die Ukraine angegriffen wir
sind in einer Krisensituation die sich
ganz erheblich ausgewirkt hat natürlich
auf die Frage von Energieversorgung wir
haben jetzt dramatisch vor Augen geführt
bekommen was eine Energieabhängigkeit
bedeutet für uns und das ist dann
Antworten geben muss und zwar nicht nur
auf der Frage wo kommt die Energie her
und wie können wir sie preiswert halten
und wie ist die Versorgungssicherheit
gewährleistet sondern was kann auch
wirklich jeder Einzelne tun also
Stichwort Energie sparen ich kann das
verstehen dass man sagt habe ich keine
Lust mich über Waschlappen kommt und
warum ist da nicht her wir sind doch
ganz genau gerade dabei zum einen neben
dem Energiesparen herzuleiten woher
kommt die Energie und wie kommen wir vor
allem möglichen sprechen
wo wir 16 Jahre geschlafen haben vor
allen Dingen aus dem Wahlkampf
rausgeholt von den Grünen und der hieß
es sie erleben ein grünes
Wirtschaftswunder mit den Grünen jetzt
sagen viele
das ist mittlerweile blaues oder Böses
Wirtschaftswunder
in der Tat also die wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung ist eindeutig nach unten
gerichtet das hängt mit der Energiekrise
zusammen und es hängt natürlich auch mit
dem Angebot zusammen das viel zu gering
ist und Habeck hat gesagt alle Optionen
müssen auf dem Bildschirm mit den Grünen
zusammen
alle Optionen müssen auf dem Tisch und
was war gerade jetzt in der
kernkraftwerksdebatte wieder erlebt
haben ist das eben nicht alle Optionen
auf dem Tisch kommen wir haben im März
einen Prüfvermerk bekommen der die Tinte
nicht wert war auf die er geschrieben
war der wurde in zwei Wochen zusammen
geschustert er wurde in kürzester Zeit
wiederlegt dann gab es einen Stresstest
der heute auch immer wieder gerne
zitiert genau das Beispiel auch von der
Wiener ist das vernünftig Frau Beck Frau
Fegebank jetzt zu sagen die Energiekrise
ist im Grunde im nächsten April zu Ende
ab da können wir dann die Atomkraftwerke
in Ruhe abschalten und erstaunlich wenn
über 30 Jahre hinweg und jedes Jahr
stärker Deutschland abhängig gemacht
worden ist fast ausschließlich von
steht in dieser Verantwortung hier der
Sprache dieser Verantwortung
ausdrücklich widersprechen
und zwar sind wir gewarnt worden wir
sind gewarnt worden von Polen
wir sind gewarnt worden von den USA dann
ist gesagt worden die USA wollen ja nur
ihr Schiefergas verkaufen es gab viele
Warnungen es wurde Nord Stream 1 gemacht
es wurde sogar nach dem Russland sein
Gesicht gezeigt hatte und die Krim
annektiert
wir wollen trotzdem gucken dass wir
nicht zu weit und zu lange zurückkommen
wir müssen jetzt Kommando ist es ist
tatsächlich
die Frage der Sie sich jetzt in der
Bundesregierung stellen müssen tun sie
alles um den Geldbeutel der deutschen zu
entlasten und haben viele im Moment den
Eindruck es wird nicht alles gemacht es
wird nicht alles getan um die deutsche
Industrie zu retten sie glauben weiter
Herr von Buttlar an das grüne
Wirtschaftswunder haben sich mit ihrem
Buch diesem grünen Jahrzehnt gewidmet
das ist gerade auf den Markt gekommen
sie haben das Buch aber schon vor Krieg
angefangen hat sie es im Grunde schon
überholt das Buch und wir erleben kein
grünes Jahrzehnt mit seinen Einzel indem
wir wieder Kohlekraft brauchen indem wir
wieder Kernkraft brauchen nein das hat
sich nicht überholt und dieser Begriff
ist auch nicht politisch gemeint sondern
wenn man sich die Aufgaben anguckt die
wir bis 2030 machen müssen
wirtschaftlich dann ist das ein Umbau
unser Wirtschaft unser Energieversorgung
und eigentlich hatte Deutschland einen
guten Plan würde ich mal sagen das war
ziemlich ausbruchstabiert in diesem
Koalitionsvertrag drin da standen die
ganzen Zahlen drin das war so drin und
dieser Krieg hat jetzt ist in jeder
Hinsicht eine Katastrophe für
Deutschland ist eine doppelte
Katastrophe er sendet bei jedem Land
Schockwellen durch die Energieversorgung
für Deutschland ist es ein spezielles
Problem Gas sollte unsere
Brückentechnologie sein und diese Brücke
ist zusammengebrochen wir wollten noch
40 bis 50 Gaskraftwerke bauen denn wie
kriegen es nicht so schnell hin mit den
Erneuerbaren das heißt zurück zur
Kohlekraft zurückzukehren deswegen wenn
es jetzt zwei kalte Winter zwei harte
zwei schmutzige Winter glaube ich werden
wir die Kohle springt immer in die Lücke
seine Katastrophe im besten Fall muss
man sagen und da habe ich noch mal
wirklich alle gefragt auch BSF und
ThyssenKrupp die Strategien laufen
weiter ist ja nicht so dass die
Gründerinnen und Gründer jetzt aufhören
ihre Start-ups zu machen also die machen
ja alle weiter die Strategien von
Unternehmen laufen bis 2030 also
kurzfristig Katastrophe mittelfristig
darf man das Ziel aber nicht aus dem aus
den Augen verlieren sie in ihrem Buch so
ein bisschen hinweg und sagen
kurzfristig Katastrophe aber das
bedeutet ja erstmal sie werden den
Menschen jetzt sagen müssen dass sie ja
massenhaft pleite gehen sie werden
Menschen sagen müssen dass sie jetzt
ihren Job verlieren und da hilft es
nicht am Horizont 2015
aber das stimmt natürlich tatsächlich
dieser Winter ist den Menschen näher als
2030 oder 2050 und das ist auch ganz
natürlich das ist menschlich und
deswegen müssen wir jetzt aber das Ziel
bleibt trotzdem richtig und ich glaube
das was Frau Wagenknecht sagt ich meine
die hat ja ein feines Gespür für die
Ängste und Nöte der Menschen aber
trotzdem ist es
das ist ja quatsch mit Soße muss man
einfach sagen trotzdem also was dieser
gesagt hat dass die Gründe gefährlichste
Partei sind okay also ich ich glaube da
projizieren sich im Moment viele Sorgen
und Ängste auf die Grünen die Grünen
machen viele Fehler aber dass sie jetzt
für alles schuld sind also für die
Katastrophen sehr Energieversorgung sind
die Grünen nicht Schuld man was man
ihnen vorwerfen kann oder der dieser
Regierung eine sehr viel robustere
Antwort ab März also hätte man gesagt
Deutschland wird alles tun also drei
Sachen wir werden Kernkraft so lange
laufen lassen wie wir es für nötig
halten egal offen lassen Kohle muss
leider in die Lücke und drittens wir
werden ab sofort unsere eigene
Gasvorkommen prüfen nur diese drei Worte
Frau Fegebank weil hätte auch hätte den
magenografie entgegen steht weil noch
ideologische Stärke laufen weiter oder
werden angefahren also auch
Kohlekraftwerke die schon zwei passiert
von neuen Brennstäben beispielsweise
also ich kann den Grünen in der
Regierung weder im Bund noch in den
Ländern ein ich kann ihnen keinen
Vorwurf machen weil genau das passiert
was eben auch waldemar Hartmann als
Vorwurf in den Raum gestellt hat nämlich
das zum der oben eine Zeigefinger und
zum zweiten
ideologische oder parteipolitisch Dinge
blockiert oder durchgebracht werden das
Gegenteil ist doch der Fall also wenn
ich mir angucke wo wir entscheiden dass
Kohlekraftwerke weiterlaufen dass wir
über lng-terminals schwimmende
lng-terminals sprechen die aus Ländern
kommen von denen wir vielleicht auch
nicht sagen würden das sind jetzt die
Demokratien mit denen wir gerne
Geschäfte machen das sind doch alles
Dinge die wir auf aufs Gleis gesetzt
haben die wir jetzt alle gerade bewegen
ohne machen schon so und wir haben doch
jetzt die drei bestehenden AKWs bis
April 23
sind
Ideologie übersetzt mit meinen Worten
den müsste ertragen naja aber das die
Entscheidung die wir jetzt gerade
bekommen haben zu den Kernkraftwerken
erstmal kam es ja nicht von den Grünen
sondern der Bundeskanzler hat Machtwort
gesprochen glauben Sie mir ist das so
war ganz kurz glauben Sie dass das ja
glauben sie die Geschichte
Geschichte dieses machtworts also war
das so sie sind doch veräppelt worden
auf dem Parteitag jetzt ganz ehrlich das
war doch vorher das war doch abgekartet
vorher und da habe ich es doch nicht
durch den Parteitag gegangen ohne zu
wissen was 24 Stunden danach passiert
eine Zuschreibung zu Robert Habeck die
einfach nicht zu ihnen als Person passt
das muss man einfach sagen ja finde ich
vollkommen finde ich ungerechtfertigt
und der Habeck ist ja tatsächlich
unterwegs
international in dem Versuch diese
dramatische Situation die entstanden ist
so abzufedern dass wir von verschiedenen
Lieferanten jetzt aus der Klemme aber
ganz konkret noch mal zu dem Machtwort
weil weil sie gesagt haben das passt gar
nicht zu Herrn Harbeck das heißt sie
glauben die Geschichte dass er durch den
Parteitag gegangen ist auf dem sie
natürlich auch fahren Frau Pflege war
nicht vor Ort haben den aber dann aus
Hamburg viel Erfolg dass er durch diesen
Parteitag gegangen ist die ganze Zeit
gesagt hat das dritte Atomkraftwerk
nämlich in Niedersachsen das wird da
wird die Laufzeit nicht verlängert und
24 Stunden danach stimmt er dem
Machtwort von es gab Unstimmigkeiten in
der Koalition und es gab dann die
Notwendigkeit schnell zu entscheiden
also es war ja immer klar dass die FDP
geklärt einen anderen Kurs wollte und
das war klar dass das auch irgendwann
aufgelöst hat
unser sparen müssen
auch ein Gespür für die Größenordnung
bewahren ja und wir haben einen
unglaublichen Energiebedarf wir sind
Industrieland und da wer ist wirklich
gut gewesen wenn wir so wie andere
Länder das auch machen Schweden als
Beispiel wenn wir gesagt hätten die drei
Kernkraftwerke die wir haben und
idealerweise auch die drei die wir
wieder ans Netz bringen können die
nutzen wir jetzt so lange bis die
Erneuerbaren ausgebaut ist ich bin ja
selbst auch ein Anhänger davon dass wir
die Erneuerbaren ausbauen aber wir haben
einen immensen Energiebedarf und das was
bislang gemacht wurde das reicht eben
nicht das sehen wir doch täglich an den
Börsenpreisen für Gas das sehen wir die
ein bisschen zurückgekommen sind aber
immer noch extrem hoch sind da sehen wir
an den Strompreisen wir müssen ein wir
müssen eine Strategie entwickeln wo wir
sagen was brauchen wir letzten zehn
Jahre und was brauchen wir da auch an
Angebot für die zehn Jahre und da kann
ich immer das narrativ kommen hätten wir
mehr ausgebaut hätten wir das Problem
jetzt nicht sondern wir hatten genau das
gleiche Problem jetzt Schaden die Grünen
ihrer Meinung nach der Wirtschaft das
ist die Diskussion in der Weigerung
jetzt tatsächlich jedes Angebot zu
nutzen ja Biomethan Gas kann man noch
dazu fügen die Kernkraftwerke auch
heimisches Gas ja Stichwort Tracking es
gab eine Expertenkommission die ganz
klar gesagt hat Tracking heute ist nicht
mehr das was wir vor 20 Jahren gesehen
haben alles das wird nicht angepackt aus
ideologischen Gründen und wenn sie mit
Unternehmen sprechen mit kleineren
Unternehmen mit dem mittelständischen
Unternehmen die haben immense Probleme
und die zahlen die Zeche dieser Politik
aber der Vorwürfe ist ja Hartmann dass
die Grünen der wirtschaftsschaden dass
die Grünen jetzt nicht alles tun würden
um den Gaspreis um den Strompreis vor
allen Dingen zu senken
ich mit doch ich gehe damit schon einig
dass sie das tun dass sie das auch mit
hirngedanken verfolgen aber es passt so
viel nicht zusammen also wenn er Habeck
nach Katha fährt das ja seit Monaten
oder Jahren verteufelt wird wegen der
Arbeiter Geschichten für die Stadien für
den Stadionbau war der
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft
doch jetzt mit dem nichts zu tun was ich
jetzt sage ich stimme die
nicht die Stimme dem ja zu zurecht wird
das beklagt zu Recht so
Habeck springt in diesem Fall weil die
Grünen das ja auch tun zu Recht tun das
Anklagen fährt dorthin um ein Deal
möglichen Deal einzufädeln mit Katar und
macht einen Hofknicks er springt also
über seine Ideologie aber
das klingt nicht über seine Ideologie
wenn es um die Verlängerung von drei
existierenden Atomkraftwerken in
Deutschland geht da muss er durch den
Parteitag und wir wurden schlicht
untergreifend verarscht es kann mir doch
keine erzählen dass er das nicht wusste
dass 24 Stunden später der Scholz sagt
ich werde jetzt von meiner
kompetenzgebrauch machen die wussten das
das waren die und der wusste dass der
halbwegs sonst nicht durchkommt kurz
zusammenfassen sie müssen beide tun
jetzt so als ob die tiefgreifende Krise
die wir haben die durch den Krieg kommt
und die kommt weil wir wie kein anderes
Land aber dann können wir uns einige
hier in der Runde die Verantwortung ist
ganz wesentlich bei denen die vorher
regiert haben jetzt durch ein einziges
Atomkraftwerk aus der Welt geschaffen
wird und das ist großer Teil aber das
war auch nicht das was Herr Hartmann
gesagt hat war die ganze Zeit auf dieser
Eigenkraft Frage vorbereitet und
Tracking ist auch noch die Frage kommt
dazu man muss in der Tat jetzt zu sehr
unangenehmen Regime gehen aber sie haben
nicht diese Macht die wir Russland
gegeben haben dass sie ein ganzes Land
für die Ukraine zerstören und das ist
ein großer Unterschied und er ist nicht
gemacht worden von den Regierungen
dass es ihnen als grüne weniger wehtut
den Bückling dort bei den Scheichs zu
machen also bei ihren eigenen Schatten
es ist eine Zuschreibung die nicht in
Ordnung ist
einfach nicht in Ordnung zu sagen ein
Minister Habeck
hatten
Punkten
das Geschäft mit Katar zu machen als zu
Hause die restideologie abzuräumen und
die neuen Brennstäbe beispielsweise zu
besorgen ja das ist ein riesen Thema mit
den neuen Brennstäben deshalb haben wir
haben wir gesagt wir gehen diesen Weg
wir verläng die laufenden AKWs auf April
23 und dann aber auch Ende
weil diverse Gesetze dafür auch hätten
geändert werden müssen
verfassungsrechtlich ist völlig unklar
ob das funktioniert und wir tun das was
nur wendig ist wir tun jetzt das was
notwendig ist um unser Verantwortung
gerecht zu werden mit entsprechender mit
entsprechender Versorgungssicherheit
nicht nur über diesen Winter zu kommen
sondern auch in der nächsten Jahre